[Music]  guess I had to go to that place  mmm celebrates ten years of sobriety the  45 year old rapper took to Instagram  Saturday to share this photo holding a  ten year sobriety coin the X in the  center representing ten is surrounded by  the words unity service and recovery the  three parts of the Alcoholics Anonymous  program M has always been open about his  struggles with substance abuse in music  and occasionally in interviews too in  2015 he opened up to Men's Journal  revealing quote in 2007 I overdosed on  pills and I went into the hospital I was  close to 230 pounds I was constantly  eating and eating badly he told the mag  that after completing rehab he lost  weight by falling in love with running  quote it's easy to understand how people  replace addiction with exercise one  addiction for another but one that's  good for them  [Music]  second road